hey everybody welcome back to another
week of top five scarin mods eluate gap
cam this is seven so why is this week
special this week is special for a
second week running I know because it's
all about the lady yes it's a women-only
episode meaning every single mod in this
episode it's like a female superhero or
just awesome video game character
yes crammed into this one episode
kicking lots of ass let's get them on
number one
[Music]
welcome everyone to mod number one and
to Victoria VG's house we are uninvited
but why are we here said well we are
kind of trespassing because we are
coming to steal some stuff
rumor is according to this mod that
Victoria vici is a huge fan of Wonder
Woman which is also the namesake of
today's modern umber one yes
are you a wonderful woman yet sir uh not
quite yet no I will let you know as soon
as I am you know what might help is all
these princess Linda boots and costume
and crying and all these wonderful
things let's take them all yes a lot so
it hasn't hasn't exactly worked I guess
it must be a female on the only texture
which is fine this have no legs Oh God
ha ha ha I say sorry Kevin what happened
your legs sir all right well let's Sam
let's let's become a female why is he
holding so tight he knows what's about
to happen
don't do this to me oh wait that's
that's wicked right good ah I'd say it
that's it yes okay
that's Wonder Woman yes okay now we need
a Shirley Wonder Woman van or door what
can we do um I mean if it's van Nord can
we go van der woman oh yes Wonder Woman
so it's van van der and here is Wonder
Woman's EV um but you know she's dressed
again I know thank goodness she's not
wearing the correct attire so let's
let's do that this starts just go
straight for the Wonder Woman uniform
boots and tiara and there we have so you
want there we have a wait how long
gauntlet gone no sorry the garnets are
us it don't really work with the rest of
there we are alright so you actually put
the coordinates over the uniform I see
now it's pretty good no sir there's
something else to be other moths we had
to install to get that particular
unfortunately but it worked because of
this the way this mod was made
it required another mod to be added
called bbp which does make some slight
body changes to the female form sure
does
ah boobs don't move like that sin oh
this is awful
oops don't do that okay this is why this
is why we have this one female mods like
this before because if if there was any
way we could have done this mad without
it we tried to install this this
particular costume without the the
additional mod and it just broke the
game every single time every time so
single time anyway the important thing
is we're Wonder Woman we're Wonder Woman
that is the ID and the costume is what
we're after costume is pretty good yeah
the costume is great this is the
standard yeah we've got for Wonder Woman
cost variations right so let's try this
one okay so this this is the same tech
like design as the other one but the
shape is different yeah it looked also
explained more contrasting it is it is
but then this one more as well which
involves stilettos I think yeah does and
this one's a bit more light okay this is
quite loud it's pretty it's pretty loud
oh they're all they're all quite skimpy
yeah but they're I think they're quite
like faiths are fairly faithful to the
original yes yeah but I do like that
instead of the whip she is of course
equipped with the zak gun naturally and
there was that famous one episode the
crossover episode of Stargate sg-1 and
Wonder Woman and Seb Luke right here is
her visible plane oh wow that is
faithful - yeah you can't have to walk
around it oh yeah it's there though
don't there don't collide with it she is
a van Lord after all kill wow that is a
lot of blood on those most bizarre babes
ah he's just not right there that is the
face of justice yeah
and slide shop good job Wonder Woman
this water is wonderful all the time
moving a bit and still lady damn it
God is there a breeze
all right same time for mode number two
I've got good news for you yeah back
inside regular breasts physics mode it's
nice the Lord here we have Wonder Woman
she's still there she's dressed for
Skyrim these days she's in her downtime
yeah yes and she's looking to meet
another superhero woman to help her
right oh oh I wish that the shoulder
there and it's slightly out of Boca
field we can see that means yeah it's
Catwoman are you Catwoman you know
follow me I need your help
ah sad we now have Catwoman about time
was pretty great let's take a look at
her hirama there looks like she is that
that looks a little bit like the
nightingale lighting go yeah yeah but
it's like a variation on it pretty cool
it's pretty cool
killer mask as well so she's incognito
yeah well I guess I can't even recognize
I know sorry
come on literally anyone I wouldn't know
how to target her friends and family
away oh god sorry go that way we got her
a little bit I'm so sorry
sorry Catwoman we got you again yeah oh
what a wonderful punch a left hook
Catwoman where did your hair come up to
her hair what gosh she must have really
taken a beating in the right place that
gun your hair away I'm so silly you know
blast it with that much electricity
though just that's what I'm her a bald
patch now we've ruined one Catwoman we
should probably get another one what we
can do is we can come over here and
craft ourselves our own Catwoman attire
woman gloves mask but we need a suit you
know iron ore of course cuz I remember
there was that great scene in the film
where Catwoman you know stitches
together her own suit oh yeah using
large chunks of iron like divine yet
naturally aha we have two Catwoman no
sir which is which have a contact from
variations on cat one which I like so we
are obviously the Arkham City yeah that
it's exactly the same like is the same
yeah it's very faithful texture ripping
off here is pretty good
Catwoman hated the law one of the
biggest disdains
Wow she is doing pretty well he's
cussing quite infected yeah
oh what's that what was that huh who
else is getting involved here black
widow but you're right to be here later
for another mod Oh God alright let's
just ignore black widow but I appreciate
her coming in here
well cepsa we up got invaded by a black
widow there so maybe we should jump
straight narrative odd number three hell
except its Natasha Romanov yeah Black
Widow is she's otherwise knowing yeah
and you know what it's actually pretty
oh come on come on aw don't be afraid
don't be friends back than fact
there we go is that it's pretty good
it's not bad actually a lot like
Scarlett Johansson
so the hairs right the eyes I son enough
they're the right color the outfit okay
I think we're just going to come to
terms with all the outfits this week are
gonna be a little bit chesty yeah a bit
Jess in black yeah lacking chesty black
and Jessie we can spine over that we can
work but this I believe is as someone
has basically reimagined the nightingale
armor for this and just kind of like cut
the front open a bit but the rest of it
is fairly yeah little dots on there on
this gauntlet a bit sir or new yeah but
it's all been made specifically for
Black Widow but it's quite the band of
female heroines we are making here sorry
sorry Kevin how is it practicing
restored swiping Eddie apology who's
stronger Black Widow that woman haha
it's on who is stronger Wow Black Widow
the old air
what sec what the were looking for her
sink to the face she's like god she's
vicious completely disabled her pipe
viewmaster
come on ladies do it Wonder Woman
demands blood oh don't it goes again
that is definitely the spell that's
gonna give her the advantage so I feel
like maybe we should step in and exploit
this patellae no sir ladies no Black
Widow hates me for God's sake they're
gonna be forever if we can just talk
this out and this is this gonna be the
fight that never ends thank you bye no I
think she's gone haha was she gone yeah
well I just hide behind this rock I no
one will seem and that was the end of
Black Widow
famously from the comic books the exact
same storyline yes sir so she drowned
[Music]
Recep here we are
Catwoman unless we who are we looking
for
Oh a subjugated ghost now we are looking
for someone in particular in this tomb I
wonder who not be there it is ah Oh No
we fell down and who's in here with us
oh it's Laura Croft oh you fell into the
trap - Oh Lara you're forever falling
onto things
did you fall into a spike I bet she did
well she's arrived I'm like this bandit
stupid bandit Zach says Catwoman
well nice that was easy at large well
you should talk her teeth are like
purple Oh textured I know thanks Jeff
follow me
oh dear purple teeth flower girl let's
just ignore the purple tea let's trade
some things there see if she sir Oh
trains your feet where did she go no
over there just row you know with her
famous Lara Croft
teleporting rarity Catwoman and Lara
Croft together thoughtful to put her in
a tomb straightaway they say we got Lara
here and her outfit is nice it's very
Skyrim but it don't worry Lara Croft
no we haven't sold this other mod yet
cold it's the road strokers Lara Croft
2013 which is technically it's like a
whole mod but we're just we're gonna
throw it in as an additional thing no
it's great because it gives you like the
ability so we'll just put on Catwoman
let's just take off art or masks and
gloves and put on the Lara body and we
can see it gives us like the classic
Lara blue tights off but it also gives
us weird Lara heads as well if you look
at the bobbing screen actually oh god an
entire new face mask so we put it on in
different forms of anguish oh god it's a
bit weird I'm telling you like it I can
tell you with some certainty that I hate
it now Lara's used to fighting in Tomb
Seb so she should make short work of
these dragger all right get in there
Laura yes
well Arnaud get up get up I think cam I
think Lara might be my favorite yeah
she's great she's absolutely fantastic
yeah she'd look at the arrows fly yes
you got him on his knee one more arrow
go on finish him finish him yes Down
Goes the deathlord zap I loves a penis
Oh Lara there's one more that's right
Larry get up get up you didn't get you
didn't get beautiful world teamwork Lara
breaking out of the gloom comedy big
yeah of course
whatever what else give me a real
challenge next time all right service
time for the final mod this week which
is Xena Warrior Princess foresee BBE and
basically what it is is just Xena's
armor but it's great
we've chucked on Wonder Woman she's had
oh yeah busy day she has she's worn so
many things I know many cut into so many
fights she has killed many a person
borrows looking very thoughtful and
pensive in the background yeah but she
no she hasn't tired at all in fact she
washed off some of the blood that she
had which was nice so the one thing is
she does look quite a lot like Xena
already but we could probably do better
with the hair suppose can I do that we
could yeah so the main thing about Xena
right it's that she's got a fringe okay
so oh that's that might be a little
extreme it's a bit much rein it in
written
oh no that's double that's not far off
that might be it there might be the
closest we can get to Xena
well should we take a look at the armor
first oh yeah okay okay so he has to
because there's this there is a number
of types actually there's two types to
choose from so if we go back and we can
see there's also a Brian
version which is very similar it just
looks a bit more like real leather now
we did look for the the weapon that she
uses
oh yes and that's called a chakra and we
couldn't find it there's no sure I mean
there are there are a couple of chakra
walls out there that are just completely
mental but none are but they're not
they're not the ones that she would use
you know they're a bit too spiky and a
bit too big they look a little bit more
like yuffie's weapon in fun oh yes yes
yes
Oh God said it's a whole pack of wolves
and SaberCats Adelina can't tell the
difference between either
ah yep Zino's had a killer Dixit Sita
famously kill animals that that was more
unknown Oh where's Laura
I know where's Laura when he do I'm
doing this for Lara Lara I'm killing an
endangered species flourish ready get in
here cat woman's involved which is
ironic sunny we're butchering SaberCats
skirts great Oh while they're really
going up on Catwoman how could you
betray us I think it's the portrayal
amazing so vicious good stab Xena nice
work everybody good weren't laid out
with great teamwork yeah yeah this is
quite formidable trio of Lara Xena
captain and I'm surprised no one's
written this into fiction before it too
bad there's no Black Widow here to round
it all off oh yeah
whatever happened to tidal river I don't
remember look it is yes so with the mod
you've got here right yeah it's not just
this you can actually remove the the
chest armor oh yeah which is an entirely
separate squad money it's actually a
shield
like it that's how it's referred to in
their inventory that is it yeah like
it's got shield icon remover it is just
regular leather armor I mean I like I do
actually quite quite like the leather
armor yeah I and it subtly is subtly
worse when you put the armor pack on
yeah the little got a bit of a um like a
cupcake thing yeah I'm getting a Madonna
buy oh there is a Madonna vibe yes don't
you know what they will not protect from
them what's that and that's a bunch of
chickens look at them they're waiting
waiting for the inevitable chicken they
know what's up a black widow were your
final charge till that chicken obey
you'll get there I believe in you feel
you'll figure that go on wannabes gonna
get it one of you must oh my god do
something your eyes running away Dever
you've done so well until now ha ha ha
that was pitiful there you go well done
guys
you were almost pitiful I really earned
that why let me show you how it's done
and if the wonder where they are
everybody get back here everyone come
back everyone regroup I just mean you
large menu boom there you go much more
effective how it's done
need something done right get Xena to do
it ah good job Xena good flight good
flight oh that was awful
that's an awful language I'm just glad
we didn't have the boob physics Tara no
oh god that was awful
well Sepp we've learned a lot today
about life and love and and fake breasts
physics I've learned everything that I
know about women
alright then they said Oh God oh dear
really I thought I knew everything
that's out I knew nothing ok spede I've
been a real learning exercise well the
learning exercise I think was really
during the install yeah we saw some
things that we hope to never see again
so here's here's the deal right so you
can it for a lot these monster work you
have to install like a female body
upgrades as it were and there's
different varieties apparently and some
of them will only work with the right so
it's like the sea BBE or so ZZ c BB e
which is the beautiful no you get
awarded when you're like a knight of the
British Republican Oh remember yeah yeah
I know what you think Republic it's
similar with me it's simpler
not quite the same more clothing
involved in the British Empire won yes
true the Queen wouldn't wouldn't allow
that but we would not approve we don't
know that but the the the mods that we
installed were body replaces texture
replaces normal mapping and meshes
replaces for those yeah the one as you
will saw for Wonder Woman women yeah
wonderful mushroom was quite something
else and unfortunately the mods it would
only work yeah the mod wouldn't work
without one that added to physics that
was very he BBP so yeah so like it's you
do have to work a bit harder to get the
the kind of female superhero modes in
there but you can do that if you want to
play Skyrim is Catwoman
that was the easy one cat one with one
thing that is you know worth noting at
least for the CB de one is that you do
get options during
install like you get with loads of
different mods in the Nexus yes which
means that you don't have to go for like
everything's a little bit over
emphasized don't let go with normal yeah
human yeah and you can even dial in the
shading to make things look a little bit
more like normal and that and also you
can make sure thing you know never-nude
is yes an option to yeah so you don't
have to see naked sky and characters if
you don't want if you don't want it's up
to you yes yeah anyway anyway served
anyway he got there that's been quite
the lesson he got there in the end it uh
we did we did promise we broke a promise
then we did break a promise we did break
poverty so we promised that we were
going to do the vote mod this week now
the thing is I like we went through and
we found so many female super we thought
why we should make the whole episode
about that exactly it made sense don't
worry we we promise next week will shows
we are yet become the yaar love iris
dead yes is one that's that's the winner
we ensure these huge modest is a huge
positive April can abate that will be
the main feature of next week and we'll
base it around that it's run away with
it it will have mod in the mod vote you
can trust us it's not like we've ever
broken your promise never ever be fine
yeah but it has totally won like it's at
a 80 something percent so many people
want to see that one
and speaking of what people want to see
said we got questions and comments we do
filling up my phone cuz I have one on
Twitter which I've received as a screen
grab because I'm very technology cam
doesn't like that I hog the air my turn
a comment so quite you side so on
Twitter shish on Twitter tech guy John
said to us a guy should stop watching at
cameras roll ban at ready said we go on
streams no as a way to avoid coding and
working must get back to work
in a bit one more vid nice tech guy John
I like your procrastination son yeah
procrastinate more yes watch this one
twice really mess up your work unless
you're coding and an awesome new script
that lets you have a Wonder Woman
plug-in mod that doesn't require PvP
which is go back to work work harder
because we need that we need that what
else we got so we have several actually
we got a comment that came in just
before we published last week's episode
saying I have a few mod
recommendations including ultimate
dragons which is a dragon mode that we
missed last weekend was from a guy
called Sterling on twitter sterling was
a sterling Archer I believe it was
sterling Archer so ultimate dragons it
looks really cool go and check it out if
you want to have a look if you were you
know dabbling in the dragon mods that we
showcased last week and she is sweep
says what was he saying I have a
question for various gamers so it's not
just for us as for you - all right pay
attention does Skyrim run and look
better on a PC then on a console you
guys want to go this one no Kemp you
want to be well seeing is there a
voiceless camera at this problem I say
yes of course of course it does it's the
whole point of this shirt well not the
whole point this show but it can be if
you've got a good enough PC yeah
absolutely you can make Skyrim look much
better and also run much quicker
yes frame rates high frame rate it'll
it'll load faster oh yes hires a big
difference actually loading - yeah
although you know if you have modded it
up the wazoo like we have through the
Moscow might you know get a little
unstable we've certainly crashed it more
than once today happen we can we sure
have we sure have yeah all right last
question this question comes from
doflamingo don't your day a name they
say are you still playing this question
mark turd brains I'm gonna seem that his
bill name is turd brain so mister brains
thanks for your question thank you
mister grace we are still playing that
is a good question and lastly as welcome
you may recall that two weeks ago I
showed off the one Skyrim Kevin man Lord
mean all you did was made who's good
what was made for us and since we
brought that up we've you know we've had
a ton in um deities so droning an hour
of music and montages let's have all the
memes that we had made for us
[Music]
such me very Kevin Wow the said that's
not the only thing that's why worthy I'm
saying okay so is PC gaming PC gaming is
the best no actually the best you know
we're doing games but at the moment
we're doing this thing called game tech
where we are showcasing a whole bunch of
PC centric content we've got art skills
about how to you know exactly what all
the graphics settings mean for PCs and
how to do all the different PC gaming
stuff that I don't know
yeah oh that's not how to overclock your
graphics cards everything now what we
are gonna do as part of this game tech
thing is we are going to with the help
of Mark Walton build a brand new gaming
PC to make Skyrim look as good as it
possibly can so it's all gummy graphics
mods we're gonna shove them all in there
yeah we're probably gonna wind up like
seven frames per second but who cares
yeah pretty much it is close to full to
realism as we can every single frame
yeah will be a beautiful photo yeah and
I'll be a man I'll be in the next few
weeks this is gonna happen absolute so
make sure you look stay tuned to gain
spot for anything game tech that's gonna
be right against our guys because
obviously you guys are assuming your PC
gamers ready why else would you watch
this show right so for us for us
certainly sound right sorry not for our
witty banter no never never it's awful
worst anyways save on that depressing
note I'm gonna go and live the rest of
my life and so will ye but we'll be back
here next week for more top 5 Skyrim
mods of the week will see them
you
[Music]